hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round five of this
year's us Chess Championship and in my
opinion it is the absolute best game
played so far as you might get such an
idea from the title of this video it's
Ray Robson versus Jeffrey shung and uh
the the game features a lot of history a
lot of theory and a lot of new ideas
which I'm sure you guys will enjoy so
don't want to spoil too much let's check
it out uh Ray has the white pieces and
he opens with E4 and both of them have
had uh not not the best tournament so
far uh they've only had a couple of
draws and lost uh I think Robson lost
two games prior to this and Jeffrey Shan
he had like three draws and one loss so
both of them would very much enjoy
winning a game so here we have pwn E5
Knight to F3 and Knight to F6 Jeffrey
goes for the petrov's defense and you
could counter this many ways Knight
captures on E5 is the main line you
could also play something like Bishop to
C4 as they would maybe 150 years ago in
the in the era of morph and Anderson you
would sacrifice a pawn uh double your
own pawns and now enjoy a very nice open
game uh which is uh you know one way to
do it maybe not uh great for today's
classical but in Blitz and bullet you
can very much play this however we have
D4 also one of the main lines uh the
idea being that if e captures on D4 you
can advance the pawn to E5 but here we
have Knight captures on e4 uh Bishop to
D3 thein its attack against the Petro
and now Pawn to D5 we have Knight
captures on E5 Knight to D7 and now
Castle so this again Main line nothing
new here captures captures and Bishop
and Knight to C5 attacking the bishop on
D3 where white usually goes Knight to C3
or you move the bishop if you don't want
to give up the bishop pair but Ray says
Nope Bishop to E3 says you can have the
bishop pair and of course we know that
this is an open game so black definitely
wants to eliminate one of White's Bishop
so first he plays Bishop D7 although you
could capture on D3 right away uh we
have Pawn to F4 and now Knight captures
on D3 and okay Queen captures and now as
okay Queen and Rook are preparing that
pawn to F5 push you stop it pawn to G6
nothing spectacular here Knight to C3
white says all right you wasted a move
on G6 I'm now preventing you from
castling by attacking your D5 Pawn so
Jeffrey now has to defend this he plays
Pawn to C6 and now while you could uh
continue bringing more pieces into the
game first REM maneuvering of the Knight
happens Knight to E2 now you want to go
Knight to D4 or Knight to G3 to help out
with the advancement of the F Pawn
probably Knight to G3 as on D4 the
Knight can be challenged with C5 so here
uh we have castles and now Knight to G3
and this is a really really awesome move
because the position has been reached
before uh in a in a very famous game
between udith pogar and um Boris Gan now
you know that UD poar is one of the
greatest attackers who ever played chess
she's basically a mik tal reborn and uh
you know if if if there's an attack in
the position she will find it she will
play it and you will you will fight for
her life to survive that attack and she
played Pawn to F5 without preparing it
in this position but gelfan the genius
that he is he was able to uh you know
just defend this very nicely the idea
was that after Bishop captures she
sacrificed The Rook G captur she played
Bishop to H6 now threatening Checkmate
Boris defended with King to h8 gave back
the material Bishop captures Bishop
captures and now Rook to F1 and now
again it looks like a very nice position
she opened up his King you have the Rook
the Knight the Knight is coming to F5
will be very dangerous but he just
played Queen to B6 check and he captured
a pawn queen captures on B2 that's how
cool Boris G on is and now she should
play Rook captures on F5 to objectively
claim a draw but she went for Knight to
D4 she wanted to activate her pieces
very quickly and then after Rook to E8
um uh she went to Knight to F3 uh to
defend the pawn here and he just played
Queen B5 offered the queen trade she had
to move the the the queen back in order
to defend the Rook because the queen
trade will not be favorable for for her
she's down material here so after Queen
to D1 uh he's up a pawn he defended well
and in the end even won the game so F5
is a bit premature so that's why Ray
prepares it we have Knight to G3 and now
Jeffrey plays Bishop to H4 he's just
fighting against Pawn to F5 because now
if you play Pawn to F5 he will just
capture on G3 and after H captures he
will play Bishop captures on F5 and
after Rook captures G captures and queen
captures white just doesn't have enough
attackers to finish this attack or you
don't even have to capture on F5 right
away you could even bring an attacker
into the game let's say queen to E7 and
Rook captures on F5 but now F6 and
everything is perfectly fine look at
this bishop to H6 you will play F
captures on E5 offer the material back
in order to go into this queen queen and
pawn endgame with black having a massive
Center here and even if Rook to G5 check
King to h8 and queen to E3 going after
the pawn here you can play this
beautiful Rook F6 move and even
sacrifice your your queen so captures
captures and captures and after Queen
captures you will bring the Rook into
the game uh the Rooks will be stronger
than a queen here but it's an open board
so the black king will not be able to
escape checks so this will this will be
a draw pretty much fairly quickly so
here Ray prepared it with Bishop to C5
it comes with tempo as The Rook on f8 is
hanging and now Rook to E8 and again not
a new position is it has been reached in
2016 in women's Grand Prix Alexandra cuk
had it against J Wun cuk played Rook 81
and she ended up winning that game but
here uh look at this what what Ray plays
he plays Pawn to F5 absolutely
incredible now what uh why is this
different than the ud pogar game and the
previous move that we discussed where it
simply doesn't work uh because it it
also doesn't work here that's the reason
uh but it does unless black finds an an
engine Perfect Defense which uh well if
you've ever played chest you know it's
uh not that easy to spot and of course
it is now as of move 15 that we have a
completely new new game so what's the
idea now the idea is that if you throw
in a nice fishion zuk Bishop captures on
G3 notice that the bishop is no longer
blocking the queen on E3 so the queen
can capture and now you cannot play
Bishop captures because Rook captures
and the g Pawn is pinned and also the E5
Pawn is defended uh you cannot capture
that everything is defended white has an
E5 and F5 U uh pawns already advanced
you will solidify with Bishop to D6 even
if you want you don't really have to and
this is objectively winning for white so
that's the that's the idea behind Pawn
to F5 but of course uh Jeffrey figures
it out he plays Rook captures on E5
right away F captures on G6 h captur on
G6 and now Bishop to D4 attacking The
Rook just claiming this diagonal for the
dark Square Bishop Rook to E8 Rook to E6
a bit more precise but Rook d8 is still
fine if if black defends well and now
look at this Rook captures on F7 we we
can even do it in slow motion because
it's such a powerful move King captures
and now Rook to F1 with with check so in
all the on all the other lines and in
the game yud pgar versus Boris Gan that
we discussed it was uh merely an
exchange sacrifice Rook for the light
scw Bishop but here it's a sacrifice of
a full Rook King to E7 and queen
captures on G6 and this is the position
uh that Jeffrey had to solve
unfortunately this is where he fell to
to White's attack to to raise attack uh
there is only one move that saves black
here so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this incredible engine
precise defense while I give you a
couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh you
know just being the greatest Defender
whoever was and ever will be and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the only move that saves the game
is King to D7 uh yes that's uh that's of
course the the the the move if you play
a bishop captures on G3 you try to
remove one of the attackers you just get
checkmated m in one the reason why King
to D7 is strong is that look at this
Rook to F7 check Rook to E7 blocks and
now you will play Queen to F5 check and
after King to C7 You'll Play Queen to F4
check and now you either repeat or after
King to D7 you have to play something
else if you don't want the repetition
okay you will play Bishop C5 put
pressure on The Rook Rook captures on F7
Queen captures and now Bishop goes back
to E7 you will play Knight to F5 with a
nice triple attack on the Bishop from
the Knight Queen and Bishop but now que
to f8 Black is happy to give back some
material of course to survive Queen to
H7 and now even King to E6 the king now
attacks the Knight and now you have to
do something if you move the Knight
you're just going to lose the bishop
with check so you have to trade here
unfortunately or you could even go for
Knight to G7 check where black would
sacrifice the queen and after Queen
captures Bishop captures and C5 with
check King H1 uh you're going to play
Bishop to D7 your Bishops are defended
The Rook is coming into the game uh and
and uh White will have to uh you know a
Perpetual will have to suffice Queen H6
check King E5 Queen to G5 check and so
on so that's the only defense that you
have here after Queen captures and G6
but if you don't calculate this you
might play something like Bishop to E6
to stop Rook to F7 which is what Jeffrey
did but now his position is Lost Queen
to G7 check King to D6 and now Bishop to
E5 with check King to C5 B Bop to D4
check repeating one more time he wants
to check if the king maybe goes to B5 or
or or maybe somewhere and you know then
some Queen captures on B7 action or he
goes something like King to C4 uh and
then you know you can start attacking
the king with the pawns uh but he
doesn't he goes back so here uh Ray
repeats Bishop E5 check King to C5 and
now Bishop to C7 and now we reach uh the
The crucial moment of the game The Black
Queen is hanging how can you defend if
you move the queen queen to D7 doesn't
work just Queen to C3 check that's the
whole idea behind moving the bishop
Queen to C3 check King to B5 now comes
A4 with check King captures on A4 or you
move the king it doesn't really matter
and queen to A5 will be Checkmate so
after Bishop to C7 Bishop to F6 was
played countering the White Queen and
now if you capture the black queen black
will capture the White Queen so here
Rook captures on F6 there's even a a
nicer way to end this and that's Pawn to
B for check I'm just going to show this
because Pawn to B4 is so crucial in all
of the lines here and even this one
because after King to B5 you have this
queen to H7 move just Sid stepping the
the attack and the black queen is still
hanging and now you either uh resign
because you're going to lose the queen
or if you try to keep the queen you
offer a queen trade then just Queen to
D3 check King to A4 uh Queen to B3 check
King to B5 A4 check uh King to A6 and
now B5 yeah you have to trade and pawn
captures on B5 will be checked M so
that's the reason why B4 here is very
potent but Rook captures on F6 is the
other winning move but Rook captures on
F6 uh it could be even more complicated
if if Ray didn't calculate this out he
would definitely find the B4 line uh
because now Rook to G8 was played and
now he only has one move to win the game
so that's what he had to find uh feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for Ray while I give you a couple of
second
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding uh the
the coolest way possible of how to bring
your queen back into the attack and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Knight to E4 with check this
is what he played and I'm sure once
Jeffrey saw this he was all right I I
see what's happening now uh the problem
is if you capture the Knight then comes
Rook to F5 with check that's the idea
behind the Knight sacrifice you have to
free up the fifth rank for the Rook to
deliver check Rook to F5 with check you
sacrifice the Rook as well and now the
queen can finally enter the attack
Bishop captures on F5 and now Queen to
C3 with check King to D5 Queen to E5
with check King to C4 and now you go
after the King Pawn to B4 check King to
B4 and now Queen to A5 will be Checkmate
so unfortunately for Jeffrey you cannot
touch the Knight he played King to B5 H
but now comes Pawn to A4 with check and
how do you deal with this if you capture
on A4 then comes Knight to C3 check King
to B4 Rook to F4 with check and now
there are two ways of playing this if
you play King to C5 of course Pawn to B4
is Checkmate as you might um you know
get an idea from the title and if you
block with Pawn to D4 you don't even
have to take with the Rook you can play
Queen to E5 and now uh the black queen
is still hanging there's really not much
you can do you can move the queen and
now Bishop to A5 with check King to C4
and now Pawn to B3 will be Checkmate so
after uh A4 you cannot capture King to
B4 was played if you play King to C4
also not not the best then comes Rook to
F4 you can even sacrifice the queen here
and after Rook captures on G7 you will
play Knight to D2 check King to C5 and
another Pawn to B4 checkmat so B4 uh so
crucial in on in all of the lines even
though he didn't play it right away so
King to B4 only other way to continue
playing this but now comes Queen to H6
and he was in this position un move 29
uh that uh Jeffree Shong resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here uh the problem is uh there there's
just no move you can make here your
queen here is hanging if you move the
queen it's a simple matter of Queen to
D2 with check King to C4 or King
captures on A4 doesn't really matter and
now Pawn to D B3 will be Checkmate or
King goes to B uh uh sorry King goes
here and now Queen to A5 will be
Checkmate so that uh will not do uh the
only thing you can do is to maybe give
up the queen let's say play something
like de capture Knight here uh but then
you capture the queen and after Rook
captures okay you have some material for
the queen but not nearly enough Rook
captures an E6 and that's it uh if the
Rook was maybe on F6 you'd have a nice
Checkmate on D1 but it's not so you will
give a nice check and after King to F2
and nothing more to be done you can
double up here you can even capture on
e4 it doesn't matter if you start
checking the rook and block uh pointless
to continue so after Queen to H6 um uh
the uh Jeffrey Shong resigned the game
and I thought it'd be weird you know
naming this video the the immortal B4
game because B4 was never really played
the pawn is still on B2 but you've seen
how in all of the line everyone knows
that the the best and coolest lines in
chess never actually get played you have
to see them in your mind uh I thought it
was it would be appropriate uh you know
maybe it's not but I I thought it would
be uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it thank you again for
recommending such a beautiful game like
I said round five usj championship in my
opinion uh the the the game to to watch
the the the best game that has been
played so far hope you guys agree uh I
would like to thank Roger Stone no need
to mention me in the video Douglas
Hooper Misa streat and Nathan Gibson for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all uh I will see you
soon and have a excellent rest of your
day